Reggie Miller the hall of famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst the 2018 NBA Awards
on TNT presented by Kia will air Monday
June 25th with coverage beginning at
9:00 Eastern aloysius how are you what's
the best name in NBA history
I do love Magic Johnson well remember
Brad Johnson mostly I said I like I
spent ooh I spent cometh and scores who
didn't have that poster on their wall I
did yes I did loved it I did
I remember Brad Johnson the quarterback
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I do and he
named his son Maximus Johnson you better
be maxima I know and I said Brad how did
you get that past your wife he goes you
know what she was in labor and I just
said I like the name Maximus and then
she didn't even think about it until we
got him home and I went good for you
ladies and gentlemen Maximus Johnson how
about finish Denbo why you gonna bring
up that name great names like that and
worries for me cook you down took you
down in the turn me down my senior year
UCLA we got them to the league you're
welcome to finish but did you realize
and like did you know anything about
finish Dembo going into that game didn't
know that yeah what other names I
remember there was a guy in Houston
anisette lava drama was a college Blair
that's a pretty good one I'm trying to
think what else la fester roads in Iowa
State and trying to think any other good
interest God God sham God has got to be
up there reg right oh yeah yes yes
that's a legend in New York City and
then he played it Providence didn't he
he did God sham God all right let's get
to the NBA Finals what did you think of
this whole LeBron James may have been
playing with a broken hand the last
three games come on man stop it stop it
look I've been on this show and you can
attest to this I've been the biggest
LeBron James apologist yeah I feel that
he was my MVP I still feel that he's my
MVP but stop I don't know if this came
from your lips LeBron but stop it you
got swept you deal with it the Warriors
won and what kicked me off because it
makes him look so weak you come to the
press conference with your hand wrapped
are you kidding me I mean this if it if
it I'm sure it happened I'm sure he did
hit a wall and broke it I'm sure that
did happen but it can't come from your
lips
it's got to come from a teammate it's
got to come from a trainer it's got to
come from a Cavs official but it can't
come from you LeBron because it makes
you look weak you can't come to the
press conference after Game four with it
wrapped you didn't come to its wrapped
after Game one you didn't come with it
wrapped after Game two or Game three but
all of a sudden you've been playing with
a broken hand for three games come on
man I love you you're my MVP but stop
man that's weak that is a weak move it
almost felt like it was to take
attention away from being swept come on
man I love you LeBron
yeah but you are a bad dude but then
stop it I think it's true I think he
probably did break it or fracture it or
bruise it I'm sure he was ticked off
after the meltdown I get that and I'm
sure he didn't hit a wall
but it can't come out from you it can
come out it could come out from jr. it
could come out from Tristan
Kevin Love tyloo one of them should say
it but it can't come from you now am I
wrong on that did he say that at the
press conference into someone else say
that because I'm sure Twitter is firing
up right now it can't come for you and
whoever taped his hand you did him a
disservice you did them a disservice cuz
you know everyone's gonna say LeBron
what's wrong with your hand
I know I know yeah you know get through
the press conference you got through the
game you tapped everybody out through
the press conference and then let the
report come out from Brian Wynn Horst or
somebody else and then then you can go
hey I did but let's not take away from
Golden State winning the title and you
know I look forward to a decision coming
up here in a couple of weeks here and
hopefully I get a chance at him again
something like that you have you have a
gig in PR video television things falls
through seriously because come on man
who's ever around
LeBron should have told him that bad
okay you can't be the baddest dude in
the league and then come out with this I
want you to tell me what Kevin Durant is
saying here he says it's easy to be the
best player when you don't have good
teammates is this a shot at LeBron or to
strengthen what KD did with Golden State
[Music]
I think he needs to take the approach of
Steph Curry and take the humble approach
and this is coming from a guy that stuck
his chest out for 18 years because at
the end of the day people are always
going to say dude you joined a 73 and 9
team okay y'all are supposed to win and
this is what our league looks like now
when you have one super team we have one
great team and 29 other okay I'll watch
them on a certain night when they play
the great game
there is zero parody and look if it's
not for draymond Green get suspended and
when the Cavs Juan a couple years ago
yeah I mean but in hindsight they don't
win back-to-back championships if they
don't have Kevin Durant so it was a
blessing in disguise for them to lose
that series on that 73 and 9 season
because they would be you can't tell me
that Kady
would have joined this team if they had
won a championship he already got
crucified for joining them when there
were 73 and 9 but they lost so people
are saying oh well he'll be the saver to
get him over the hump what she did
back-to-back championships but he
doesn't join them if they win that
championship
where did where's the most likely
destination for LeBron Oh God you and I
we've been talking about Houston in
Philly
that's probably being the two
frontrunners yeah but now I'm here in
New York I've heard you'll probably take
a meeting with pop in San Antonio
I heard New York out of left field
maybe teaming with Paul George you have
porzingis comebacks the LeBron
sweepstakes especially as the draft
grows near because the Cavs need to know
what the what he's going to do and once
I believe free agency is July first
I don't think LeBron knows I really
don't think he has no idea but LeBron
has to ask himself this question what's
more important getting back to the NBA
Finals what he has eight straight now
nine straight eight straight NBA channel
he's got to go to it if that's if that's
what's important to him then obviously
Philly in Houston will probably be the
to likely destination but I've been here
in Boston which I can't see what kind of
read there Kyrie wouldn't be happy about
that unless he's part of the trade yeah
they would they would trade Kyrie I
think about that Kyrie he wanted out to
get away from LeBron go to Boston
to set up his own legacy just heard
halfway through the season
Boston finds a way to get to the
Conference Finals in the East and then
LeBron comes in and says okay I'll take
over from here
would you rather play in New York with
Chris Paul and porzingis or play with
the lakers New York because there's only
one way to go up in New York and that's
I mean they haven't been in the playoffs
in what six or seven years and they are
dying to have a marquee superstar look
to me the Knicks sound like a likely
destination if he can find a way to get
Paul George mmm and then Chris Paul to
go there along with porzingis wouldn't
you have to say they would be the
favorites in the east know in who so
Boston and and Philly
well I don't know porzingis his injury
status you know the fact that they said
he could miss next year as well so I I
would rule out the next and I just I
don't see him dealing with the New York
media reg he just come to press
conferences with his handbag so let me
clarify this Paul George
Chris Paul and just LeBron where would
they finish on the New York Knicks in
the East
so you're saying Boston Toronto and
Philly are probably still better
wait now it's LeBron Chris Paul and Paul
Jory and Paul George oh okay
no no porzingis because let's just say
he's out for next year yes just a he's
out furniture so just those three that's
pretty good you could you know I'd put
them up I think Boston is because of
this these injuries Boston will be even
better because those kids got some run
Philly you know I want to see if Philly
has another gear that they can go they
can click into because they they had a
big jump but now is when you become a
great team and I don't know if Philly's
ready to become a great team
and just really great to have a look
this is Reggie Miller saying this would
be great to have the Knicks back
seriously in the playoffs and competing
for a championship yeah
it just would be nice wishing spike
spike is a BA ready to give up his seat
would you rather be three and six in the
NBA Finals or five and two in the NBA
phone or five and two in the NBA final
yeah 5 and 2 so that's Kobe yeah I would
rather be 5 and 2 in the NBA Finals as
opposed to 3 and 6 in the NBA Finals
where 9 and LeBron is versus 9 trips to
vs. seven trips yeah I want to be 5 into
what did you make a David West saying if
you know you guys only knew the drama
with this please let it out can we find
out what's going on someone has to know
something reg you should be able to find
out something I want to know what this
is there must have been major major
drama behind the scenes ok but what
could that drama be for Golden State may
be a power struggle among Katy and dream
on probably some words being said with
Steve Kerr I would assume Steve Kerr is
strong-willed yeah but what do you are
they fighting over touches being a star
being demoted I like I'm trying to
figure out how dramatic it could be for
the Golden State Warriors well someone
needs to butter up David West and let's
find out him no need to get a couple
drinks didn't even find out exactly the
NBA Awards on TNT are you part of this
NBA Ward show intend to I will be there
it's on our network ok that's Monday
June 25th then you have the uncle drew
premiere later on
oh my damn it yes you've done the red
cover together okay yeah but I don't I
don't I don't know if they're gonna let
everybody walk down the red carpet like
you're okay well I'll be walking down
the red carpet yes you and I'll be
walking down the red carpet all right
Dennis they can like just wave how about
that they could wait for it at the end
of the red carpet okay because it does
get awkward there when you walk down the
red carpet and then nobody asked you any
questions because they don't know who
you are
or they'll that's the time they change
the battery on their camera or the or
they'll look down like they don't and
then I'm making eye contact with all of
them like just just somebody asked me a
question yeah because if 71 that they
make love it good what is the second
most interesting thing this offseason
aside from LeBron Kawhi Leonard is that
whole how are they going to resolve that
fractured relationship between Gregg
Popovich the Spurs and quite Leonard I
mean will they ship him can they smooth
it over I mean we're talking about a
top-five player I want to see how that
unfolds personally yeah it feels like it
makes more sense that he's gonna want to
get that max deal and are you gonna sign
and trade him and what do you get for
Kawhi Leonard in San Antonio you won't
get quiet Leonard value back that's for
sure
what if LeBron went to San Antonio and I
put him with Lion Aldridge oh I love it
but then the East is oh my god I know
you have a Houston San Antonio and the
Spurs and the Warriors
yeah that's great and Popovich yes I
would love that I would love for him to
seriously look at Gregg Popovich and the
Spurs but also your your
be able to play everybody gets to play
their position if LeBron goes to San
Antonio part of my problem is with the
Lakers
you know what do you do with Lonzo ball
with the Sixers what do I do with Ben
Simmons if it's the Celtics what do I do
with Kyrie all of these places you have
somebody in place now they're not LeBron
but in San Antonio you know there's not
gonna be any argument there that LeBron
is gonna run the point there I don't
know how many other places realistic
places he can go to where LeBron can
still be LeBron and you know not you're
not sacrificing anything if you're one
of his teammates and you have the
perfect setup and mixture of players
because you need bigs that can shoot
threes and spread this floor so you have
that in LaMarcus Aldridge and Pau Gasol
you have guards that can are drop-dead
shooters Danny Green Patty Mills and
another coming young stud in dijon Ste
Marie yeah so the infrastructure is
there in San Antonio you have a
soon-to-be Hall of Fame coach and
Popovich a winning tradition in culture
with the Spurs to me it makes sense the
question is do you want to butt heads
with Houston and Golden State in the
West or do you just want to see one of
those teams come in da finals teams
which he's done in the last you know
well he was old career Hey just a public
service announcement Barkley said he's
gonna smack somebody in the face if they
bring up the LeBron Michael Jordan
comparison so just letting you know
don't bring that up to Charles or you
make it today probably right good
remover on this show where you don't
compare no we do we don't compare no we
do now they're both equally great but
people need to stop with the water
cooler talk about who's the goat and
who's the greatest right now LeBron is
the greatest in today's game in his
generation Michael was in his and we'll
leave it at that okay so we'll see you
what am I going to talk to you again
you're gonna talk to me after the draft
on June 22nd so we can find out where
everyone is going and what teams got
better or worse
and then we're gonna come in to do
myself and a few of the uncle drew guys
right yeah on the 29th I believe and
then we're gonna walk down there ready
together in New York City oh I hate that
red carpet thing what are you talking
about all those Adam Sandler red carpets
you know it's always a given you know I
never like it because I know all I want
is one person to stop me that's it and I
guarantee you more than one person once
you do not you on the red carpet I'm
gonna make sure of that all right if you
could maybe have a plant could you put
somebody in yeah I don't care yeah yeah
just have some be like Kevin Frazier
from Entertainment Tonight he'll stop
and say hello to us done deal all right
I'll talk to you soon thanks for the
invite with the uncle drew movie that's
very nice of you
Theodore you are the best it's the least
I can do Dan net you guys are truly the
best Thank You Raj that's a Reggie
Aloysius Miller jr. that there for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]